asked for a few jacques bond lowry  unable to get that layup to go  anderson has laverto on the trail  [Applause]  selling it and they bought it got that  one i mean when you  use that much body language on a play to  me  that should be called the flop and you  know how much i love kyle lowry but this  is  that that's like that should be a fine  i mean i would honestly go and review  that one  i wonder if they will because that was  that was and i'm not blaming kyle i  would i'd do it too if i get away with  it but that was  so a technical foul justin anderson  gives them time  to ask kyle lowry for his screen actors  guild card yeah i mean i tell you what  oscars might be in his future  so lowry you make the call here  yeah that that's stationary and it's not  that the official's  in a bad position but he's got a bad  angle to see that call  and and i'd be frustrated as well if i'm  justin anderson  because it was a bad call